la saison de koh lanta la légende touche
à sa fin saison auld base pour les 20
ans du programme avec les aventuriers
les plus emblématiques de l'histoire du
jeu
greg l'épreuve phare un programme qui
avait de quoi tenir toutes ses promesses
j'ai jamais vécu une aventure assez
difficile pourtant tout ne s'est pas
passé comme prévu la fin des guinées
clandestins a pris une ampleur sans
précédent
d'avoir avec des hourras exclu de
l'aventuré pour avoir bénéficié des
aides alimentaires vous avez demandé à
des pêcheurs qui passaient au large de
la nourriture puis les révélations
faites par le parisien sur les dîners
organisés pendant la nuit par plusieurs
candidats à couple leur aurait donné
tous les trois jours de la nourriture
est alors que la finale va se jouer ce
soir entre trois aventuriers hugo
laurent et claude des tricheries
vont-elles être sanctionné y aura-t-il
un gagnant et 100000 euros vont ils être
reversés à une association ou vous
faut-il une finale 100 gagnant à
quelques heures du verdict nous vous
faisons toutes les révélations en
plateau
merci mr slim myriam palombes à neutre
avec no mercy wafa d'être là ça va enfin
oui c'est vrai alors et vous avons assez
collante eig incroyable alors on a dix
info à vous donner sur koh lanta vous
donner les dix info ce soir avant la
finale déjà
depuis quelques semaines le nom du
vainqueur circulerait par nous mais
l'émission de ce soir pourrait tout
remettre en jeu myriam qui est le
gagnant suppose et on savait qu'il y
avait un gagnant qui était supposée
alors de qui le gagnant supposer c'est
claude voilà c'est pour ça que la
dernière fois je vous disais que pour
lui toutes ces histoires de tricheries
parler d'une omerta contre lui parce que
beaucoup de candidats savaient la suite
de l'émission et l'issue de l'émission
bien sûr alors à priori maintenant ce
sera plus claude badis ouari youri c'est
plus claude voilà c'est saint gilles
voilà alors c'était son nom dans l'urne
il avait gagné et déjà ça posait un
problème parce que au moment où
l'épreuve s'est tournée où on a voté
pour claude claude il était encore le
candidat bénie par la production est un
contrat sur tf1 et d'après nos
informations certains aventuriers
avaient voté pour lui un petit peu
incités ou se sentant inciter à devoir
voter claude donc après ils se sont dit
non mais attendez on nous a plus ou
moins poussé à voter claude et voilà ce
qui s'est passé donc c'était impossible
d'ouvrir lui ont-elles qu'elle était
donc elle ne sera pas ouverte ce soir là
j'avais besoin pourquoi vous avez des
infos là dessus parce que vous avez
suivi la saison pour vous c'est la
saison de la honte où c'est la saison de
la légende
moi je suis triste de voir que koh lanta
ça fait les gros titres
pour moi c'est une magnifique aventure
vous mangez vous
avez fait 2010 et 2012 2010 et 2012
n'avait pas mangé du tout j'ai rien
manger du tout d'ailleurs j'ai fait un
malaise sur les poteaux et peut-être que
si j'avais mangé je n'aurais est allé
voir les révélations qu'on va vous faire
c'est incroyable parce que vous allez
halluciner comment savoir ce qui se
passe ouais voilà donc là vous êtes déçu
vous avez passé pas fini autre info
deuxième info pour la première fois du
jeu la finale du jeu ne sera pas en
direct c'est ça ouais alors la
production a longtemps réfléchi ce
week-end ils ont reçu certains des
candidats rim laurent et l'autre pour
essayer de leur faire entre guillemets
avoué qu'ils avaient mangé alors non pas
avoué justement alors d'ailleurs les
finalistes étaient convoqués par tf1 ce
matin à 10 heures est pour pré
enregistrés cette finale et certains
d'entre eux ont filmé les coulisses dans
une vidéo on entend claude avoué à
demi-mot la crise et évoqué la
responsabilité des protagonistes en fait
c'est laurent qui faisait un placement
de produits va enfin démasqué disait que
des baskets ses baskets voilà c'était
sympathique et derrière et d'ajouter on
entend claude c'est incroyable 4 c'est
nickel dans le ton bras quand même on
est acquis la sortie donc bravo à lui du
pari de regarder
c'est qu'il a la faute de tout ça
pendant vu la faute de tous les
candidats à la preuve que monde à chacun
son déchet
incroyable ça c'est incroyable mirial tu
l'as vu ça
c'est cool au ty en train de montrer ses
baskets
40 ans super forts comme louis et après
ils l'ont remis mais que la musique non
je ne crois pas qu'il ait donc pourquoi
ils ont enregistré cet après-midi alors
l'ambiance était pas très bonne il
manque à certains il manquait combat il
manquait alix thé où il atterrira était
là mais il enregistrait pas ce qui est
tout simplement ils ont eu peur d'un
règlement de dinde 1 500 en direct les
aventuriers
ils ont eu peur que d'autres leur dise
mais attendez vous avez entre nous
franchement c'est une erreur monumentale
excusez moi je vais jouer je dis rien
hein j'adore la prod et wii se voit la
catho mais c'est une erreur monumentale
moi il m'arrive ça mes frères mes zip en
direct le nécessaire mes frères je
redonne des canifs
non mais les mecs sans déconner non
franchement après ça mais franchement
c'est une catastrophe de faire ça donc
de l'enregistrer brûle alors je vais pas
regarder je n'ai radâmes dans les rades
ap je vais vous dire voilà c'est vrai je
comprends pas de cette saison de koh
lanta tout le monde dit qu'elle est en
dessous et en dessous en termes
d'audience en dessous en terme
d'histoire la gloire au bout des signes
clairs mais on en parle dans toute la
presse et il ne joue pas le truc il
aurait dû faire comme on aurait fait ici
dans tpm p une émission spéciale avec
des rebondissements les accros des faits
but émission de
vidéos comme celle là il faut la jouer
dans koh lanta c'est hyper fort pour
faire ça il y en avait mais nous on
voulait tout gâcher en fait depuis des
bisons policiers visent comme ces
sorties sont obligés les courts après
l'avion de m oui mais il aurait pu
assumer parce qu'en plus il n'y était
plus ou moins au courant des tricheries
parce qu'un meilleur show en fête a été
écourtée au départ elle devait s'unir un
dimanche et l'ont avancé au nouveau
didot clairement il était au courant de
tout tout s'est fait à quoi peut-il les
candidats sont sortis à 19h15 seulement
dont qui les ont longtemps maintenu
candidats participants pour pas que sa
fuite si vous voulez tout à l'heure on
vous dira ce qui s'est passé mais c'est
vous qui déciderez faut qu'ils aient
toujours les bonnes choses
et donc c'est vrai que l'ambiance était
hyper particulière ce qu'on peut vous
dire déjà c'est que la production a
bétonné le truc c'est à dire que pendant
l'enregistrement d'après mon envoyé sur
metz la promo
c'est pas comment arrêter l'absolu mais
s'est arrêtée parce que c'est
insupportable la production annuelle
m'intéresse pas laisser la production a
dit nous avons les preuves mais selon
nos informations ils ne les ont pas
montré pendant l'émission que les
téléspectateurs verront ce soir voilà
ils apprendront serait une photo oui
trois heures exactement troisième un fou
il semblerait que lors des conseils les
candidats auraient tous eu la
possibilité de manger alors ça
incroyable folie non mais je vous dis on
a des infos de fous là c'est que le
début il a déjà ça commence à monter en
puissance jules ferry oui beaucoup de
choses alors il ya eu les deux fameux
dîner le dernier theora le dîner dans le
bungalow il ya eu parfois des bananes et
du coca donné par la production d'or ce
qu'ils étaient faibles et c'est vrai que
tous les candidats ont mangé il y avait
des citronniers quand il allait aux
conseils sur l'allée la production avait
pas vu que c'était pas des airs y avait
des citronniers donc plein de vitamine c
est avec du piment le piment c'est vrai
que ça donne beaucoup d'énergie donc il
mangeait tout ça et je vais vous donner
une mauvaise nouvelle cyril donc ça ne
veut pas c'est que ce que l'on sait que
selon nos informations il y en a un qui
était celui dont tout le monde disait
lui au moins
selon mes informations
hugo aussi à manger non tous man show
c'est à dire que quand ils revenaient
des dîners les deuxièmes dîner dans le
bungalow il rapportait de la nourriture
aux autres pour que les ont pas
lancement et je crois qu hugo a cédé à
la tentation est ce qui l'arrangé dark
ride à manger d'après l'un bas sur mais
oui il vous avez des infos oui
effectivement les 10 nice est choquant
après gilles parlé de des bananes et du
coca c'est pas la première fois que la
production donne à manger où l audace et
ça arrive et ça arrive et quand même
c'est incroyable alors wafa quand un
sens à ta vie je mange et toi tu avais
donné de malheur nous vous avez donné un
milkshake à la banane avec du chocolat
mais c'était vraiment pour qu'on ait du
peps juste avant les épreuves aller voir
les infos sur koh lanta qu'on a à venir
là elles sont folles encore dîner
clandestins le nom des candidats à
l'initiative enfin révélé alors oui vous
entendez bouleversé que la 4e info vous
rendez compte km en fait non on savait
déjà que y'aura avait fait rapatrier de
la nourriture sur son île est en fait
les deux protagonistes de ce dîner
colons distincts s'est close up et
laurent qui sont en jeu pendant que ça
moi c'est
depuis maintenant claude et laurent
c'est claude et laurent et en plus ce
qui est assez dingue c'est que il aurait
parce que voilà ils se sont fait donner
de la faim donner de la nourriture par
les gens par les touristes qui étaient
sur place il aurait proposé voilà de
leur donner de l'argent une fois rentré
en france il s'agit crois pas moi alors
alors si si par exemple une photo ja va
mieux alors il sort et la mairie croit
pas il aurait même été surnommée latine
en fait ils ont été surnommés la team
roublard par leurs collègues d'après une
info du parisien une nuit à 3 heures les
deux candidats auraient pris
l'initiative de quitter ce campement
poste conseils pour aller mendier de la
nourriture il aurait aussi été à
l'initiative de repas chez l'habitant
pour l'heure pour les convaincre clos
dès lors on aurait promis de leur
envoyer de l'argent une fois en beach
voilà exactement l'argent je pense à au
moins on dit que oui sauf que le
gouvernement donne est pris en photo
d'accord exactement très tôt donc une
preuve matérielle existerait de ce repas
elle est aussi trop tôt il aurait été
capable de jouer une maison c'est à
saluer la prod l'a récupérée et la ville
va les récupérer
franchement c'est c'est hyper dur mais
là le la prod à la fouillouse le
cloisonné évidemment nous ne sommes
informations que la prod aurait bien sûr
renchérit pour garder cette photo c'est
ça la faune est allé à tahiti a demandé
aux gens de la guinée des photos je sais
qu'un jour il est mal placé une photo
qui a été effectivement prises à tahiti
rider de fer rigoureux et que québec a
demandé et que quelqu'un récupérer et
selon mes informations ce quelqu'un
c'est un ancien aventurier qu'il l'a
quand il a récupéré la photo je peux pas
donner son nom quand il a récupéré la
photo il est allé voir la prod ou tf1 il
leur a dit voilà soit soit vous vous
prenez l'initiative de dire ce qui s'est
passé moi je fais tous haute école en
coulant c'est là où ça a dégénéré cette
photo moi je ne les ai pas vus mais
j'écris j'écris une parfaite manche et
voilà ils sont grands lacs aloïs
entraînement voilà il ya quatre
personnes sur la photo quatre candidats
sur la photo il n'y aurait jamais claude
laurent et si les annonces jeanne ans
peut pousser
l'équateur et enfin ceux ci que tu
entends des difficultés sociales sinon
toute la vérité anta diop femme est
connue c'est malheureusement de nos 6 à
h à 10 à durcir les mares tu vois pas
que c'est pas bien oui alors il faut
préciser moi j'adore jade je n'ai pas vu
la photo mais j'ai parlé aujourd'hui
avec quelqu'un qui a vu la photo la
photo ils sont mis à quatre candidats et
cette photo effectivement à les entendre
en train d'être achetés et le prix va
sortir le mieux
acheter elle et elle et elle est
acheminée le prix le prix de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros oui majeur
dizaines de milliers d'euros que je veux
dire cette photo elle va sortir de tous
les
locaux qui favorise sur tech des locaux
qui l'ont aussi et je désespère pas de
la voir cette photo cette photo afrique
alors oui et la production et la
production est allé là-bas pour empêcher
que cette faute au sol mais ça n'a pas
suffit d'aller cinquième enfant affamé
les candidats auraient été jusqu'à faire
les poubelles et oui qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire en fait ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est une année compliquée pour
ces quatre géants
quels conseils ils sont sur une rive est
prêt à tourner sur leur île ils doivent
prendre un bateau y après 45 minutes et
en général ils le font pas le soir ils
dorment sur place dans des tentes et ils
repartent vers 5h et donc là il y avait
cinq courses les nerfs les cinq
containers du complexe hôtelier et il
allait manger il y avait des touristes
qui les ravitaillent et les poubelles
pour leur donner à manger qu'est-ce qui
est le plus hallucinant et c'est pour ça
que c'est un peu bizarre que la prod
fasse comme si elle découvre des trucs
tout d'un coup c'est que la sécurité qui
les surveillaient savait pertinemment
qu'ils allaient fouiller les poubelles
alors là vraiment si c'est le cas c'est
une grosse erreur de la production parce
que les femmes s est ce que tout ce que
ton ce soir ça
va tirer sa grosse erreur de la
production de laisser des poubelles
sachant qu'on est très très affamés
claudine un rapport très particulier
avec la nourriture j'ai fait koh lanta
avec lui et à la fin ils étaient prêts à
manger le lézard et la prod m'a dit non
non non il était là avec sa machette si
vous voulez manger tout ce qu'ils
trouvaient est en fait la de laisser les
poubelles on les fait les poubelles
alors autre info la nourriture
clandestine aurait été directement
livrés en paniers repas à domicile
claude laurent et leurs trois acolytes
dont sam et fils le troisième n'est pas
confirmée aurait réussi à se faire
apporter des repas nerpa sur leur
campement par les autres qui les avaient
nourri chez eux à deux reprises l'homme
qui le recevait les ramener en voiture
aurait joué les livreurs c'est alors
c'est un énorme d'arcachon livrer des
repas sur volontariat
oui voilà avec kesha le la alors quid du
bâton est tombé ce serait ennuyeux sky
le conditionnel ce serait le monsieur
qui a alimenté teyou
il a pensé à ouvrir un petit truc
mais un petit peu deux ans je savais que
oui alors et donc ouais et donc c'est
lui qui aura apporté régulièrement fin
en tout cas de reprise sert pas pour
lesquels avec lesquels tout le monde se
serait rassasié laissé deux fois là
incroyable mais c'est vrai qu'au moment
ce jeu c'est hot gentil a dit mais ça
fait plusieurs fois à chaque fois après
le conseil vous me demandez des repas et
il faudrait peut être penser à mme
rémunérés et c'est là où il y aurait eu
effectivement une parole échangée des
promesses de
rémunération d'accord et je ne sais pas
si c mandat ou un virement mais il y
aurait bien eu en retour en métropole
une rémunération c'est en lozère et
quand même j'ai mal pourquoi former
ma vie
non pour moi koh lanta c'est pas ça non
c'est pas ça koh lanta
koh lanta c'est la survie c'est voilà
c'est la maîtrise et la survie sans
voilà alors j'ai d'autres tu vas tu vas
lui signer ouais j'ai encore quatre un
fou qui sont folles sur les nerfs des
candidats auraient quitté l'île en plein
tournage selon nos infos les candidats
se sont énervés c'est surtout en
apprenant les tricheries un compte
épargne d'un associé résultat outre et
certains auraient menacé de tout
dévoiler trois aventuriers aurait refusé
de poursuivre le tournage et serait
rentré en métropole sous escorte de la
production une rumeur indique que
certaines scènes auraient même été filmé
à paris vrai ou pas alors bah oui c'est
ça oui c'est c'est ce qui paraît
effectivement non mais on voit très peu
un d'image de lille où ils se regroupent
tous pour le jury final au début on a
cru que c'était parce que clément ces
combats s'entendait pas donc la
production à éviter dans le de mettre
ces images mais en fait est que trois
candidats auraient vraiment pété un
plomb et du coup on les aurait rapatrié
en france et est du coup la prod aurait
décidé de filmer à paris des images où
on les voit voter on sait pas si on
verra ça ce soir les candidats dans la
maison candidat là
mais là ils sont partis s'ils voulaient
ils sont partis et du cou du coup la la
la prod pour attraper un peu le truc
aurait filmé des images à paris mais on
sait pas encore si l'ambiance était
catastrophique là bas l'ambiance avait
été catastrophique il y avait ceux qui
allaient manger faut que ceux qui
sentent exclus après donc ils ont décidé
de partager c'était trop tard et
d'autres ont dit que le jeu était truqué
certains mangent d'autres pas ils sont
donc plus en forme sur les épreuves donc
ça ne va pas et donc à ce moment là il
ya une vraie clash autre info
ils restent 3es elle seule chose en
matinée je vous dis bah oui ça remonte
en puissance
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
parce que là je déprime auraient été
versés aux polynésiens pour acheter leur
silence alors vendredi vendredi 10
décembre
joe cole en panne ces dynasties
alors réunion qui a été demandé par par
la production ce que faut savoir qu'il
ya 387 locaux qui ont travaillé sur
cette île pour koh lanta et du coup leur
affaire petit coup de pression pour leur
dire que voilà fallait quelque chose
arrête de fuite et est donc pour pour
les aider à se taire pour leur aurait
donné une prime en plus ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que lors de cette réunion
il y avait quand même les trois maires
des trois communes de l'île plus une
autre magistrate de lille plus le
ministre de la culture politisé
puisqu'il termine quand même eux ils
sont médias furax parce qu'ils ont quand
même investi un peu d'argent pour eux et
c'est d'ailleurs s'il aimait faire
parler pour faire venir les missions sur
place et puis là non ça donne une image
catastrophique de la polynésie vous
aviez la bb1 faut que j'avais exactement
la même info et c'est vrai que pour les
polynésiens sont ils étaient très
contents d'avoir ça et finalement c'est
une calamité donc attention qui info
deux incroyables
info deux incroyables wafa
[Rires]
j'attends bref assez incroyable ouais
selon le parisien claude et laurent ont
fait du chantage aux membres de la
production lors d'une épreuve de confort
la récompense de l'épreuve était un
retour sur l'ancienne île des jaunes on
pouvait y trouver deux coffres un
premier avec qui contenait un indice
pour récupérer un collier d'immunité et
un second avec le courrier des familles
de huit candidats ainsi que des
viennoiseries des tablettes de chocolat
du manioc est acquis aux deux pattes
après avoir menacé de faire grève les
candidats ont obtenu des pains au
chocolat est ce que c'est que cette
histoire
là c'est bon non mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ces dix ans il servait le
petit déj
alors chaque année il ya cette fameuse
épreuve de confort ou voilà c'est un peu
la lal la séquence émotion où les
candidats hawks il gagna peuvent lire le
courrier de leur famille sauf que là il
y avait des viennoiseries dans le coffre
est bon et du coup laurent notamment et
claude était dégoûté de ne pas avoir ses
viennoiseries laurent aurait dit style
font chier par presque usées mois pour
le charme mais
voilà avec leur courrier moi j'ai grave
j'ai graffin et du coup ils sont menacés
lui et claude de de faire grève et face
à sabha la prod a lâché lors si la
finale la prod est fautive là c'est pas
possible tu fais grêle en a moins de
droits que c'était la croissanterie
insolente et passe en scooter
voilà les bars et l'abonné décroissant
faire après tout le d'un très très fort
caractère et je l'adorent moi je t'adore
oui moi pour moi c'est l'un des oui mais
quand j'entends tout ça ça me fait mal
franchement c'était l'année où il aurait
pu il a gagné sans fin où ils auraient
pu gagner sans ça parce que surtout les
koh lanta qui l'a fait il arrive au bout
de cent a fait ça qui arrive sur les
bateaux à chaque fois et la faire sa
passion dans une folle chocolat vous la
connaissiez alors je la connaissais il
faut quand même pour être totalement
honnête et congrès léger un des deux
candidats dont on parle moi il me il me
dément ça il me dit que c'est vrai mais
c'est enfin alors ça m'ennuie de le dire
c'est un des deux indes et de gouaille
en photo dr vous me direz pas d'accord
c'est
l'accord donc c'est pas non mais moi je
veux juste
bien non mais je dirai simplement
passer la provoc légal reviennent de
kolontar et trois kilos de plus
mouassa ya quand même un problème
enfin un faux numéro 1 1 il n'y aura pas
de vainqueur pour cette édition ils cent
mille euros au profit de l'association
pour bertrand kamal c'est la grosse
rumeur qui tourne est ce que c'est vrai
oui ouais bah c'est vrai mais comment
c'est pourquoi ils vont dire quoi pas de
vainqueur bref maintenant accueille oui
pas de vainqueur la la tricherie est
tellement énorme que ça ça devient
compliqué de cautionner tout ça c'est
aussi donc ils ont décidé de ne pas de
sauver les apparences ben rien n'est pas
de dépouillement du corps c'est la
grosse rumeur tv
oui sans émission je vous la confirme
cyril cc voilà c'est ça va très
probablement valeur face à va se passer
comme ça c'est à dire qui aura pas de
vainqueur c'est impossible de donner 100
mille euros à claude donc du coup c'est
très bien là la fondation bertrand kamal
qui a pris la décision c'était ça ou la
prod c'est la prod ambiance avec
l'accord de taëf absolument absolument
surveillance
délétère très compliqué tournage a eu
six ans pas de questions directes 1 de
nick qu'on m'a décrit un peu gêné aux
entournures tout à fait normal donc une
soirée c'est tellement compliqué et la
production maintien ils étaient ils
étaient plus gêné dans district ced
et la gêne est d'animer district est que
de ne pas d'avoir deux vainqueurs dans
kolontar m et sert il vous dit où vous
pour rien à faire un truc là demi mots
comme ça sur la pointe des pieds à
l'asie en dire plus balancer quoi que un
vrai pro il faudrait une vraie émission
c'est vrai c'est un vraie prise de
parole exactement on explique tout et
qui me veut exactement ce que nous
l'avons fait d'accord dire on le fait
nous on le fenomeno c'est ce qu'on va
faire on va le faire nous mêmes oui bah
si vous le choix soit là les deux mains
sur la tête de ma mère on va le faire
nous mêmes
demain demain on le saura et demain on
va le faire et demande à tous ballon si
ces langues de moyaux
[ __ ] dosage balance tout balancer pas
mal
contre eux et j'espère vraiment que la
prod va le faire c'est qu'elle va
prévenir tout ce qu'on vient de dire là
ça veut dire que s'il n'y a pas de
vainqueur et qu'on fait une émission
comme ça dans le vent
mais elle va le dire mais le valais soit
évanouie bien sûr c'est ce soir c'est
l'émission oui mais moi je pensais qu'il
fallait dire non je pense qu'il va le
faire avant l'émission parce que tous
les fans de koh lanta qui regardent
l'émission et qu'il est la vraie vie
sauve pas tant pas lassé des rumeurs
dieu dira alors ses dessins photos et
dessins font ils sont dans le parisien
ce soir quoi voilà mais si ça se passait
il aura fallu qu'ils préviennent avant
parce que ça se fait pas les gens
entraient très les vrais fans de koh
lanta qui vont pas avoir vainqueur c'est
pas vraiment le contraire vraiment les
gens qui sont fans ils veulent bien
sauver des mines énorme énorme plaisir
non ils veulent pas fait rire point là
c'est une info qu'on nourrit on va les
vérifier c'est pas sûr elle se voit là
c'est une info quel parisien aussi on va
pas se mentir c'est tout le monde parce
que c'est celle de la qualité au
conditionnel myriam d'autres infos c'est
bon c'est bon
demain vous balancera tout wafa ça va
très bien je suis déçu mais c'est pas
grave alors tu vois pas en chocolat